Sabe aquela panela antiaderente que você
usa todo dia? Pois é, ela pode estar
envenenando suas bactérias intestinais
agora mesmo. Olha só, acabou de sair um
estudo mostrando que nossas bactérias do
intestino estão absorvendo os chamados
químicos eternos, os PFAas.
Esses compostos estão em todo lugar, nas
embalagens de fast food, nas roupas
impermeáveis, até no papel manteiga. E o
pior, elas não saem do corpo, vão se
acumulando. Veja bem, se suas bactérias
intestinais estão absorvendo esses
químicos, isso pode estar bagunçando
toda a sua saúde, desde a digestão até
os hormônios imunidade. É como se o seu
intestino virasse um depósito de
toxinas. Quer uma dica prática? Troca as
panelas antiaderentes, o intestino
agradece e as bactérias também.